alors nos monuments aux morts qui a été
inaugurée en 1922 précisément le 11
novembre le monument aux morts c'est le
symbole de la première guerre mondiale
ces collégiens ont travaillé sur celui
de leur ville pontarlier
ils ont aussi conçu des notices
biographiques sur ces soldats morts au
combat
alors maurice pato on a ça tu peux nous
montrer ça ton peu digne tristan donc là
on a ça tombe il habite et où plus de 20
heures rue de vannes hall il est mort à
quel âge on a dit ce matin 22 ans on
voit où c'est qu'il a été enterré
on voit son son nom et qui sur sur la
steg
ça fait bizarre loin si avec l'aide de
leurs professeurs leur travail a donné
naissance à un livre qui rend hommage
aux soldats
donc ça c'est une photo de soldats de
l'arrondissement de pontarlier ensuite
comment ces notices qui sont classés par
ordre alphabétique bateau où sa photo
et puis ça c'est une lettre donc de la
famille du plateau je m'étais jamais
imaginé que je resterai un livre en fête
du coup du content je suis contente du
ranger parce que on a quand même
travaillé je te pousse à ces jolies avec
les soldats devant la porte saint pierre
qu'il représente pour tarder ils ont
effectué leurs recherches sur des sites
internet spécifique
ils ont également travaillé sur des
documents provenant des archives
municipales ou du registre de l'état
civil
qu'est ce que ça t'a apporté travailler
sur 14 18 comme ça pas du respect pour
les soldats qui ont qui sont morts pour
nous pour la france le nombre de morts
en en pendant cette guerre c'est non
je m'attendais pas ce que les gens
meurent autant en fait j'ai d'abord
travaillé dessus c'est pour nous rendre
compte que ça fait une guerre et pour
éviter de recommencer
je prends surtout que si à la guerre
l'humanité va être détruite
[Musique]
résultat de leur travail un nom va être
ajoutées sur le monument aux morts de
pontarlier celui de marie louise et la
bonde infirmières touchés lors des
combats elle meurt de ses blessures à
l'hôpital de pontarlier à l'âge de 28
ans
[Musique]